حسب الصحيفه البريطانيه هناك ثلاث جبهات
يمكن ان تكون ساحه لهذه المعارك الضاريه
في الربيع المقبل ويمكن ان يكون حسم اي
واحده منها منعرج حاسما لهذه الحرب جبهه
الشرق ونتحدث هنا عن لوجان
التي كانت مسرحا لاشد المعارف في الاشهر
القليله الماضيه هي اكثر الاماكن احتماليه
لشن هجمات
في الربيع جبهه الجنوب ايضا هي الجبهه
الاهم بالنسبه للطرفين الاوكراني والروسيه
لماذا لانها ستقررون نتيجه الحرب برمتها
سواء جنه القوات المسلحه الاخرانيه هجومها
الاول في الشرق ام لا وتبقى جبهه الشمال
حيث روسيا قواتها للتدريب في بيلاروسيا
ولكن يبقى هذا الامر خدمه من قبل موسكو
لابعاد القوات الاخرانيه عن الجنوب والشرق
ودائما بحسب الصحيح